yeah hello and welcome to this video
which covers round 9 of this year's town
of steel tournament yeah what did we
have in ROM 9 we had a couple of drawers
and just one decisive game it said a big
spoiler it is a bit of a spoiler but
again you probably know the results
anyway it's a bit of a late video but
even though there were a couple of
drawers things got really really wacky
so let's have a look they're going to
kick off with the game nippon-ichi with
white against pintle harikrishna and
this game already in the early stages
shaved up to be very very sharp this
looks quite modest but white has some
interesting ideas with this move it's
something that I've played myself
he's six plate and non Deponia she took
on d5 this is a very rare move white
usually plays Bishop c4 in this position
like this or the move deform this is for
example what I played in a game last
year this has a very concrete idea
because nipple now goes with before
that's a bit of a shocking move but it
is quite interesting if black now grabs
this bone which is probably not all that
great then we should be to is giving
white very nice compensation white has a
permanent grip on the d4 square and it's
difficult for black to develop because
the bishop is so strong it's very
difficult to get this get this untangled
and something like f6 just looks ugly I
think Harry Krishna's choice of c4 is
stronger and yeah the time spent
suggests that they both have had both
know this position it should be true we
should things before yeah he took on
before probably yeah probably okay it's
tough to again develop if you don't give
up
g7 porn so Bishop g7 rook g8 and Bishop
e5 of course he also could have just
gone back to be to this is really one of
the weirdest positions after a couple of
moves that I've seen on the board after
such a let's say relatively conservative
opening like the English here it's
really a yeah really non-standard now 96
attacked the Bishop on d5 and the bishop
retreated to g3 so all of a sudden the
bishop switched to that diagonal of
course on g3 it does have some points
especially it covers the g2 pawn or
let's say yeah blocks the rook from
attacking and so white prepares his
development this all looks fairly
logical in my book h5 getting this on
the road black work a so long anyway
that's what it looks like yeah now t3
here by manipulating and this now leads
to absolutely crazy complications I
think that Harry Krishna is playing it
correctly and I mean mostly the computer
things because the game now gets so
complicated that the human the pure
human eye is very difficult yet to use
and this is what they have to do during
the game so Bishop f4 note that wide the
Y players not spending any time at all
yeah that could mean that he had this
prepared or that he's maybe a bit
frustrated with the tournament's course
the period she has not won a single game
and lost lost one or two if we look at
before round nine I would have to check
that I think it goes to UM so d4 now by
Hari Krishna interesting choice opening
everything up
he takes d4 and here it seems to be a
critical situation
hurry Krishna now does not play Bishop
h3 you just suggested by the computer
this is certainly a move that he
I mean ended quite obviously with the
exchange so it is a candidate however
what we shouldn't do is just like fire
this away under okay black wins an
exchange because let's just just say we
get this position the exchange is nice
to have but note that the black king
will never be safe in this game ever
yeah it has no porn shield while the
white pawns him shield the white queen
king quite reliably and also a bishop
can be a pretty strong piece in this
kind of position it opens up quickly for
example let's say black takes on d4 and
white plays a move from a group b1
attacking this pawn this is not just a
straight exchange out for black
absolutely not
still this is probably what Harry
Krishna should have gone for he played
this and this is met by a strong reply
because the permian she just takes on c4
and the point is that black now does not
have anything better then to play what
he did he took a 92 Queen takes and now
there is a choice between just being
permanently worse or yeah probably be a
lot worse but be a lot worse in a murky
position this is what we can see now
using all kinds of analysis tools in the
game it's not such a clear decision he
could have played Queen d3 which is
probably not much fun as we see here
white as a pawn up but black has the
bishop pair and will not lose
immediately there are some scenarios
like this like rook the 895 Bishop e6
like this where we have opposite colored
bishops I think here the black drawing
chances are quite quite decent I mean at
least it's great compared to what what
happened in the game in the game he
played Bishop d3 and
wonder exchange on f1 but this is a
situation that is even worse than the
exchange up then we looked at earlier
here White has a pawn for the exchange
as well and extremely active pieces
note how bad the black king is it is
absolutely yeah impossible here to find
an absolutely safe place for the serve
at most important piece yeah rook c8 is
what her accretion I did Ruby one
looksies Roxie six and here already the
engine gives some improvements white is
a lot better here but finding this over
the board now is difficult the strongest
move seems to be Queen to h5 this is
preventing rookie six because of the
pinning idea this move and White has
some ideas to continue Bishop g5 for
example or c5 Bishop d6
white is a lot better here it's however
difficult to the ad to compare those
continuation that all have may look good
and he played this move which also looks
extremely extremely dangerous for black
there is Knight a5 potentially coming
this is a tempo move but after rook g6
Black has gained a tempo as well and
after g3 takes takes he played King to
f8 you know the Queen h5 earlier was
probably even stronger even though what
position here is very very good as well
we seem that after rook t1 and now look
at the two threatening discoveries there
is an extremely critical position now
here after Luke f6 played by Hari
Krishna that was not the best offense
rupees six was better it
yeah here we have a situation where
Napoleon Sheena could have won the game
two straight win the game but he did not
find it he played this move and
relatively quickly and he blitz the
whole game which is kind of yeah I mean
the whole game at least up to him which
is kind of showing that maybe he was
just frustrated with everything I don't
know but 95 is not exactly rocket
science and wins yeah we can we can
check a couple of lines so what happens
here with this move first of all the
queen is attacked if the Queen takes
check Bishop h6 is the key idea King e8
is a direct made checkmate
so the rook takes and we grab the Queen
and our could be a queen up for rook and
Bishop plus a winning position so there
is no danger here at all
so what is the thing rook takes but here
again yeah check and the check just
wrong only Bishop d8 is playable and
white wins the gene and this pawn so
it's queen against two rooks but white
is two pawns up and has a continuing
attack yeah we will win even more
material as both a and f7 pawn are weak
it's a complete win it's a bit
mysterious Knight f5 is of course it's
the first move you check in this
position and somehow it was not played I
think it's really strange
yeah you'd look for the discoveries
first and the lines are super simple I
mean it's a bit weird he played Queen h5
which is still dangerous of course but
Knight f5 the game probably would have
finished in a couple of moves okay Queen
h5 it's still again very difficult a six
public Bishop g5
and it's not fun not fun for black b6
and we get into a position again where
white is probably close to winning it's
just that the black position is so tough
to defend yeah here 9 f5 again blankets
in huge trouble and the next couple of
moves are all very very much forced yeah
and now here 97 King to 7 check check
it's the best move rook to 6 and here
again he played this immediately and
instead Queen f6 is the end of the game
f7 will drop under much more favourable
circumstances than in the game for
example like twin c6 chantix
chantix and then Knight f5 and this is
unbearable for black even even endings
could be it could be winning sometimes
it's tricky here because the black king
is so close to the pawns but even some
endings to win here yeah this is a bit
better I mean sorry there's a lot better
than the game in the game we get
something similar he played this first
and then went here yeah
but now black is a bit more active
especially the bishop here and here
there is no clean win the problem is a
four point is weak and the winning idea
would be to push the pawns like F and G
pawn which however exposes a white king
a little bit later we get through
acquisition again where white could have
won and I'm not saying that how we
crucially defended badly the black
position is just a total a total
nightmare to play so we can go forward a
little bit to that position where check
there was an opportunity again however
this is difficult to spot yeah King G 2
was played by white player here and
instead it seems that instead of King G
too hot to the engine give that Queen f3
seems to be winning but this is
something that is a pure computer chess
I mean to get to see a difference
between all those gems that looked if
that looks similar is really tough this
is the idea of the engine pushing the
pawn to g6 and it might indeed lead to
win it's difficult to analyze this
conclusively but we can look at a line
for example like a for King g2 this is
not forced this is just for showing what
what could happen made funny idea King
b7 check check and then the F pawn check
check and white wins the extremely long
line of course not even the engine
calculates like quickly this farm it
just that it shows some some potential
winning ideas that that there are in
this that there on this position and
it's really nothing to be folded for
what what nippon-ichi did white is
pressing the whole time but check it
like black it's just holding by just by
a tempo I mean look at this the a pawn
is just quick enough to be enable here
to promote and there's an even as you
have a check check and white gets this
with check but it doesn't it does not
really add up then black is fairly well
coordinated and black always has
potential
perpetual x' so at the end this ended in
a draw even this is not all that easy
she had it ended in a draw check check
check
yeah and blacks counter place is too
strong super checks
this is hanging here they agreed to a
draw so a very disappointing result for
the Russian player I think at times you
just played far too quickly it seems and
yeah and lost some or also missed some
opportunities to win the game the next
game I want to look at is and if you
it's soft it's tough to believe but it's
even was even crazier than this one the
game unbreaking with white against
public alien off and Dracon plate the
Trump something that he plays relatively
often he's got a quite a wide collection
of offbeat openings and the Trump is one
of them so um a 692 h6 yeah now I think
white probably should play just 93 this
is the Torre attack solid opening very
simple development everything's okay he
played this this in itself is not OK
cannot be terrible but what I'm getting
at is black now played Queen to b6 and
now you have to do something with the
b-pawn and it cannot really sacrifice us
at this stage so he covered it with rook
e1 and black managed to play e5 and hmm
I mean for my taste
the black is already very okay here his
development is okay and he's putting
this this big porn on in the center so I
mean that cannot be a great opening
result
he just played 92 now and black decided
to grab space in the center which in
doubt is almost always a good idea g5
Bishop g7 so black now has a
considerable space advantage however
white development is not so bad it's got
pieces at least ya moved away from the
starting positions but they're not very
effective it's probably equal ish but in
a very uneven way yeah it's a very
unconventional position so they both
canceled and now Andre can started yeah
some active operation I'm not sure if
this is a good head yet or he went
before trying to expand on the queenside
now at age 5 Bishop d6 so he tried to
transfer this bishop somehow to c5
however we see that the bishop has no
squares it's actually kind of a self
trap so what happened he went b5 sorry
he went f3
sorry this is the thing he went f3 and
not B 5 B 5 was a bit a bit more
circumspect but okay the thing is f3 d6
sorry III b5 this is an AK it's crazy
III b5 so why does counter attacking the
knight and haven't here already an
interesting decision because black has a
couple of options
some don't lead to anything yeah like
taking and white takes is not it's
nothing special this is going to be
taken probably equal ish this position
then there is what he played which is
not bad at all and there is Knight a5
and this is probably the strongest
option just move the knight
it seems that white does not really have
a great reply to that for example after
b6 black is just going to move the
like here and what is this night doing
now it goes here black has a great
square here he keeps his porn and
something like this for example
it's very okay from likea black is of
course somewhat better hard to say how
much it's so extremely murky 95 was
probably good alternative but early
enough place b6 he has absolutely no
issue in this game to put as much oil in
the fryer as possible so b6 takes and
takes so now the night it's hanging in
the whole time the night now has to do
something it went here C for 9 to 5 and
again there no interesting choice barely
enough he could have just taken on c6
simple move very simple move and black
is fine there's absolutely no no big
argument down Black is fine but I enough
did not want to be like that say simply
better he was just playing far more
ambitiously and went Knight f4 now after
rook e1 again he could have taken but he
played Bishop f8 asking a question what
are you going to do with the night yeah
and this was answered with Bishop f4
white is keeping this pawn this is
probably not the greatest decision but
it leads to a fantastically
fantastically complicated position so
early enough now takes the knight wide
recaptures he has got a couple of sheep
bones now and 93 yeah this is an
extremely strong piece on d3
and yeah right now has little choice
actually yeah you you don't want to keep
this night there and play rook everyone
that's just an extremely passive move so
and Regan decided to just give up the
exchange this is probably objectively
speaking not all that great but from a
practical point of view it's very
understandable so grabbed it and rook to
e8 so why didn't exchange down and he
has this extremely strange configuration
with the C pawn and the very strong
knight on d4 the big issue is actually
that black has this very strong III pawn
if it wasn't for that pawn I think
White's compensation would be very good
but this way the e pawn is such a such a
substantial nuisance for white that he
probably cannot have enough compensation
in the game
h4 was played I mean white has to get
something going rookie seven takes takes
yeah and now of course white could have
played like slow moves but well that's
not the spirit of this position and I'm
drinking went with a spectacular route
b7 simply offering another another
exchange okay
takes and white gets a point to b7
the next moves now I think is really
quite mysterious because the most normal
move here in this position is simply to
take the pawn and return or be ready to
return the exchange but it was not
played now which is really surprising he
should probably just take the pawn and
if white tries to get it back there is
not that much going on I know it looks
dangerous but it's it's not it's not
decisive in any way big issue again is
the e pawn it's not so easy to do
something with wine that he can take
here and maybe go for this this attack
but something like Queen to the aid
which covers that is just keeping
everything nicely coordinated for him
the next move will be e2 and why doesn't
have enough he decided not to return the
exchange I mean not because he like was
so happy with the exchange probably had
some something calculated that he didn't
like any played rugby aid and now white
keeps the pawn so why does two exchanges
down for these two parts and yeah an
extremely nice knight on d4 in a game
between two humans with limited time
this position is I mean I'm not saying
that this is equal has something but
it's like anything can happen it's it's
such a such a messy position um in them
next moves black is doing fine like this
92 the light wants to regroup f6 and
Queen to d1 yeah I enough is playing
this nicely now actually he gives up
this pawn with a check check to get the
rook on the edge far the only mysterious
thing is right here I mean I understand
it's a little time but here the move
rook e to a 8 which looks like the most
normal move in this position does win he
must have missed something I'm not quite
sure what but this is winning the game
for black after something like f1 which
is covering this there is the key move
Queen to f7 maybe he did not appreciate
how strong this movers it's impossible
now for white not trade if he plays
something like that for example there's
Queen g6 and this is an decisive entry
of the Queen
or alternatively this one yeah check and
black wins yeah yeah it's a very long
line I mean but you don't have to
calculate everything when you play
rookie to h8 it just looks more natural
to me than playing Luke 2:8 but it's um
it's extremely tough the funny thing is
that now in fact if you believe the
computer and I tend to do so because
this is just pure tactics this position
it's already a spoilt position for black
and it seems that white has enough now I
mean those pawns are quite dangerous
this was played and now have four it
seems that this is just about to hold
for white f4 rook h1 was played on Queen
f7 there is 94 and again black it's not
winning somehow yeah yeah that was
played yeah and the white king yes just
taking a wrong but there is no checkmate
and at the end never forget for example
after a Queen trade potentially and
white might win with those pawns
so here and Bishop d1 had to be played
it's the only move but yeah if you have
only only moves are sometimes the
easiest to find Knight f4 ya note that
this is no good
yeah yeah because your black comes first
okay and will win but Knight X is good
yeah yeah the white king only form but
there is no mate there's not even that
many they're not even that many checks
right now is tons
material down but look at those pawns
and white has yeah
big counter counter ideas here to at
least draw so he played this okay yeah
yeah after a couple of checks yeah yeah
yeah yes I agree to a draw
yeah what a game there was like pure
chaos absolutely pure chaos and yeah
draw at the end maybe it's it's a right
result yeah after such a complete mess
yeah a lien of probably could have
should have whatever win won this game
but it was so extremely extremely real
and complicated that he did not manage
with the whole time
yeah note that he also had a winning
positioned around before but struggled
in the in the time in the time trouble
face and okay the there's one more game
that we could look at because but it's
extremely long it's a game via Audubon
where ye was better the whole game but
ultimately did not manage to win it was
a 90 plus booth game that I don't want
to look at because there's one more game
that definitely needs to be checked
which is the game Carlson event very
with white cousin fine really
and yeah as you can probably guess
because of my early spoiler this is
going to be not a draw so we have a
Sicilian when really as sticks to his
guns but now place the the traveling and
variation of ravening and yeah not too
frequently see nowadays because it's
widely accepted that black cannot
equalize against the Charis attack with
g4 so bit surprising maybe even really
wanted to get in a surprise because it
usually plays the night off okay
g4 was played back
age six - really and here white has
quite a substantial choice the absolute
main move is the move H 1 followed by
Luke G 1 tried to play G 5 after all
this is probably a bit better for why
this is what is widely accepted at least
another option is what Carlton played he
just played a normal that's a developing
move with Bishop g2 and in this
situation after Knight C 6 H 3 we get to
a position type that is quite well known
from the night off
when white plays the move 6h 3 it could
easily transpose if black now played B
should be seven and a six those kind of
things in the game fan really played an
interesting move which is maybe not that
great but interesting again g5 it looks
a little bit weird maybe to some because
yeah they're not familiar with some
plans in the Sicilian the general plan
is very very commonly known black plays
g5 - being able to capture and pawn on
f4 and thus securing the e5 square
ideally for night so this is a
strategically a very ambitious idea this
is also typical when really it doesn't
like to play yeah smallish maneuvering
stuff he wants to play ambitious chess
and white now can play in various ways
Bishop e3 just developed normally let's
say or can play what Carlton did because
of choice is one of those keep it simple
decisions but not a bad one he took on
c6 and play d5 the idea is that now
black well black will probably do this
and was played in the game and now white
takes and here you see what Carlton's
idea was white pawn structure is just
going to be a little bit better
white has to porn Islands
three points on each side of the board
and black is on three porn Islands so
not all that great in comparison
this cannot be a fantastically big
advantage but certainly it's comfortable
and a position type like a little bit
simplified and kind of manageable that
Carlson is good at
so when VD took it with the Queen
castles Bishop a6 and rook to e1 yeah
white is more comfortable it's just what
it is it's difficult for black - yeah -
imagine how you can equalize this is
often a big problem you're sitting in a
position where like here your structure
is a bit weaker and you don't have a
clear plan how you could change this
because the pawn structure is not likely
going to be improved in the near future
you just have to be stay active
it's the main thing he played Bishop to
e7 94 Queen c7 and here Carlson found a
good move and it's a move based on a
tactic always check in a game if the
opponent has got unprotected pieces and
if there is more than one unprotected
piece or even three unprotected pieces
or more then the likelihood of some
tactic working is increasing a lot and
here white has a little tactic that is
strong not like a tactic that wins the
game but c4 is a strong move and this is
based on the unprotected state of the
rook on h8 if black takes then queen d4
is a straight double attack so c4 is a
strategically very desirable move that
is technically justified by that double
attack 24 you haven't really move the
knight and cars and played b3 so why was
c4 so so good for white because it keeps
the bishop
on a six completely out of the game the
night on b4 is also I mean it's a lot of
bad piece because it can exchange itself
but that leads to simplifications that
why does not
yeah not unhappy about Luke t8 twin F
393 black had to do that basically if
you don't exchange the night now it
might be stuck on on before the move
Knight c2 is can reject a serve rejected
refuted by Knight f6 check King f8 and
Queen C 3
this is not great yep and this is
checkmate and at the same time the queen
is attacked of course that's a bit
cooperative but it shows the dangers 93
was played rook t1 and now the trades
were unavoidable so what does not change
is what was happening earlier the pawn
structure is favorable for White Queen
f4 played by event valley and now cars
decided to simplify matters
yeah and the pawn was lost
what's their way to avoid that for black
here we took with the bishop if he takes
with the king janak d1 is actually going
to lead to a fantastic attack for mind
so he only had the choice between yeah
being in this situation which is
probably losing like this walk going to
the pawn down ending and this is why he
went for the pawn down ending however
this is clearly not much fun the c6 pawn
ultimately dropped Bishop f3 and it's
fast for the moment knight c6 is the
idea has
to be stopped and now the c-pawn got me
moving
Roxy eight and yeah here white had to
had to take a decision play what he
played or look for something else there
is actually not yeah I mean you can play
other moves but c6 um is transforming
this position to a root ending which is
probably winning so it it's tough to
question this decision black might want
to take and take on c5 so you have to do
something concrete and you cannot easily
move the knight yeah because we should
be v is extremely annoying let's have a
look what you did Carson just now
transforms this into a book ending takes
takes takes takes and now we cut the
rook ending yeah he rejected rugby seven
rupees seven check and taking on a seven
that would have given white two
connected passes but they are relatively
far back it seems that this what he
played is a pretty clean technical
solution white is a pawn up he still has
the better structure and note that this
is two against one on the Queen side
which is actually better than just
having a passer because the passer in
itself will not promote on its own
accord here the rook we will see later
no it's it's not not later at this pawn
sorry this a pawn is something that
requires protection and this is why two
against one is even even better this
structure as we see here already is also
quite likely to lead to a scenario where
white might get a past age pawn so the
ending is extremely bad for black maybe
it's losing you haven't really took him
and now try to activate this book
but that doesn't help at the end note as
I said this is a weakness he has to yeah
keep the rukon v m and yeah some further
maneuvering let him bite ruku entering
Jay Jay Jay and the apron dropped black
couldn't really do much about this it
was an extremely bad root ending you can
probably improve the defense a little
bit but I don't think that at the end it
would have would have saved friend
William it continued someone moves but
yeah yeah here the Dutch player resigned
so I round 9 saw six draws and cards and
winning so he's a little bit back in the
race he has he had lost this game
against report in round eight but with
this wind now it's kind of like nothing
efforts yeah if it is still behind
Wednesday so have a point there after
round nine yeah it was a fun round -
despite the many drawers I hope you
enjoyed the coverage thanks for watching